good morning it's still here he's still
here so hank and i had an idea which was
to look at our tweets from 2011 but
because i'm smart i deleted all my
tweets from 2011 a long time ago but
instead i guess what we're gonna do is
just look at what i tweeted 10 years ago
yeah so these are hank's piping hot
frozen cold
10 year old takes here we go thank you
portland for an amazing night i may
never wear shoes again
ah there's going gonna be a lot that i
do not have any idea where they came
from well i'll tell you what the people
loved it it got nine likes
this is another tweet that reflects the
sort of 2011 aesthetic of a quasi stream
of consciousness twitter feed who the
hell got potatoes all over my phone i'd
have to assume it was me i am stuck
inside of around 20 t-shirts i literally
cannot get out of them by myself the
initial panic has subsided i now accept
my fate i remember this yeah i don't
remember that very specifically yeah
that was a vlogbrothers video uh-huh
yeah there's a lot of shirts you put
yourself inside of 20 t-shirts try to
like break a guinness world record or
something silly it wasn't even close so
it's just like a challenge i was not
able to get out of them by myself this
is a good one even though it only got
three likes just did some official
counting 993 dollars to keep it 879
dollars to shave it uh oh keep it made a
comeback oh god like this
this huge huge mistake huge mistake huge
mistake it had a very large effect yes
and you still have to deal with the
after effect yeah which is that the
first episodes of scishow and crash
course were both filmed with a goatee
you know what let's bring it up there it
is goodness gracious how did it happen
why did it why was it allowed to go on
why did people donate for that to remain
well the thing is i tweeted that shavit
was winning yeah and that was the
mistake big mistake tithio's cover fact
john's name is now as big as the title
which means that he's kind of a big deal
when did that book come out it came out
in january of 2012 this was october of
2011 so i had just seen the cover for
the first time yeah and i actually as i
remember it there was so much negative
response to the cover yeah you were
trying to find the positive spin
people did not like the cover
it turned out that the cover did pretty
well
turned out it was a good
cover all right hank we have here a
tweet about hank green the celeb chaser
is there anybody nearby who could
potentially get me in touch with
skrillex
14 likes
why did i want to talk to skrillex next
next tweet
catherine and i just broke into
someone's house then we took their dogs
for a walk does everybody else like the
everyday i'm shuffling song as much as i
do
i don't know if that was like a little
ironic because it was big already or if
it wasn't big already and i was like
on the on the like catching the catching
wave wow that's a true snapshot
sometimes i re-realize that the way we
communicate with each other in the world
is being revolutionized
and it is exciting
which it was
in 2011 still exciting back then it was
exciting in the way that you feel when
you're going up a roller coaster yeah
and now it is exciting in the way that
you feel when you're going down the
roller coaster but you're actually going
further down than you went up and you're
like wait how far how far down does this
go this tweet only got 15 likes but i
really love it from the research i have
done i am willing to assert that there
is no abominable snowman i think he's
totally abominable
i'm actually going to retweet it right
now hank i will continue to see you
right now all right every day
i want to retweet that nobody laughs at
their own jokes like hank green